dans l'île de france les dégâts sont
très importants notamment dans l'oise
val d'oise les yvelines
mais c'est à versailles que la tempête
semble avoir fait le plus de ravages
dans le parc du château
plus de 4000 arbres ont été déracinés la
toiture a été endommagée
florent muller et marie richard le parc
du roi-soleil saccagé par les vents en
deux heures près de 4000 arbres
centenaires se sont inclinés devant les
bourrasques de 122 m eur aujourd'hui
vers ça y ressemble à un château de
cartes
certaines fenêtres ont volé en éclats et
les échafaudages menace de s'écrouler
devant ce désastre les déesses de pierre
en sont réduites à jouer les
charpentiers de fortune selon un premier
état des lieux la tempête a été plus
violente encore que celle de 1990 qui
avait déjà coûté des millions au château
il cela pourrait s'aggraver canada il ya
des trous un peu partout dans les
toitures
si la pluie arrive alors qu'on ait eu le
temps de pas chez de ferveur on aura des
dégâts redressable là c'est un peu une
course contre la montre qu'actuellement
tout le personnel est en train d'essayer
de boucher de connoter très vite jusqu'à
nouvel ordre le château est fermée au
public
car la forêt particulièrement dangereuse
à versailles un homme a été tué par la
chute d'un arbre et de nombreuses routes
ont été éventrés mais les arbres ne sont
pas seuls en cause rue des chantiers on
a frôlé la catastrophe
une grue d'une trentaine de mètres s'est
écrasé sur un bâtiment en construction
les vents l'ont arraché de sa base et
celle ci est venu s'échouer dans le
jardin de la résidence voisine
tout s'est joué à quelques millimètres
pour les propriétaires de l'appartement
du dernier étage un peu secoué c'était
sais pas je pense j'ai jamais entendu
une bombe mais pour moi c'était un peu
comme une bombe
quand c'était une énorme bombe qui tombe
à côté de notre immeuble parce que
finalement nous on était encore vivant
oui mais les morceaux de grue à côté oui
il est coincé entre légumes s'était
redressée et pour moi je me suis rendu
compte que je devais être miraculé toute
la matinée françoise et son mari ont
tenté de joindre un couvreur
en vain il faudra se faire au goutte à
goutte du plafond tendu et pour la
fenêtre on se contentera quelques jours
d'un carton personnes dans l'immeuble ne
comprend pourquoi cette grille n'a pas
été démontés malgré l'avis de tempête
d'autant qu'à quelques mètres d'autres
menacent toujours
qui tombait sur l'épaisseur moi je me
sens pas la patte avec mes enfants je me
sens pas d'histoire de le faire je sais
pas c'est pas facile 3 de dormir et
qu'on aura presque pas trop loin des
crues cependant je trouve ça j'ai peur à
la gare de meudon là encore on est passé
à quelques mètres du drame
un arbre a transpercé la voix une pincée
de secondes avant le passage du train et
de ses voyageurs
mais bien souvent le choc a été
inévitable
en ce lendemain de fête beaucoup se sont
réveillés avec une triste surprise et ce
n'est pas forcément au père noël qu'il
faut en vouloir